okay so here we are a while ago my
friend adam challenged me to make a
japanese omelette called omuraisu for a
video
i did it sort of okay not really there's
one guy in particular in kyoto japan
that makes the most perfect awesome
looking one turns out the guy chef
motokichi saw the video and said hey if
you come to japan i will show you how to
make it myself
and so guess what
we're in kyoto i'm here with riya again
i've never been more scared in my life
he's a nice guy let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
even more handsome in real life
so today i'm going to learn how to
actually make omura yeah what should we
do first
okay so you're going to start by making
the fried rice
this pan is awesome it looks like it's
made a lot of rice
can i hold it oh yeah
that feels good though under your lefty
ready
[Music]
oh i have to do it with my left hand
yeah in a professional kitchen you have
to flip the pound
left
that's going to make it even harder for
me i think i just want to watch you make
it first okay
it's like up a foot
you want me to do it
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
i'm not going to be able to do that for
sure
okay about
[Music]
salute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is it lemon lemon-shaped
it's melon
play and mold has to be shaped
very nice
viet said that you put milk in with the
eggs and that's why i couldn't do it no
no salt on it i was hoping that there
was a secret that i was missing
for why i was doing it so badly
about it
[Music]
very very difficult uh so why is it a
different pan
[Music]
this is very high heat
okay okay
outside oh wow
just coming
[Music]
the omo app okay that's like super cool
[Music]
yeah just like that right they go there
waiting
okay waiting
[Music]
[Music]
to
um
[Music]
okay yeah that's
just that easy huh
very delicious
wow
yeah the demi-glace is awesome smelling
the sauce is so rich the egg is amazing
the egg is a sauce in itself yes
well i'm glad i get to eat this because
all of mine are going to be trash adam
come in
so good so good
yes i don't want
[Music]
i feel like how you feel right before
you go on a roller coaster oh
it's great pants i like your pants
yeah
thanks you got everything figured out
oh forget about it
fire on
good
boom oh good oil time mother oh great
mother means like no yeah
yeah
be happy
okay
uh one scoop in there
good spatula chicken
i'm doing it with this hand
i saw you do this yeah
all right
i'm not ready for that one that's hard
mode one two
one two
one two three one two ooh cha-cha-cha
one two cha-cha-cha okay one two three
something like that
okay ten beans yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
about okay we're gonna do like yeah okay
that much
the rice
oh
yeah good good
okay
all right
one ladle yes yes
36
cc
okay
make it sing
make it strange
how do you do it so easily show me the
motion
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
good making a giant mess i'll knock it
down i have rice sticking
soup
then like wash the pan right right now
okay
yeah yeah yeah from there turn this on
good wait for the next step yeah okay
okay okay
it's b
okay
okay
yeah
okay cool man that looks like the easier
half of this
[Music]
that's it yeah one ladle right should i
let it get hotter
okay
feel like i already messed it up
so i already filled this omelette but
we're just doing this to practice
change oh
come on that was it yeah okay yeah yeah
oh
very hard oh
okay okay a little bit softer
oh yeah yeah yeah oh okay
okay
yeah
hey did you just hear
my production managers whisper this is
stressful on screen
thanks
and then make the omelette
if it doesn't roll by itself you can use
the chopsticks
yeah okay so we're just rolling it so
that it lands on its uncooked seam so
that it seals up okay
yeah
okay
[Music]
[Music]
don't rush
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
okay stop stop stop stop stop stop stop
stop stop stop
stop don't don't do anything
okay the bottom is ceiling
push it into the push yeah push it into
the corner
okay yes good okay okay okay
okay yeah hey oh oh the chopsticks go
underneath
okay
okay okay
okay let's cut it
[Music]
ready
all right ready yeah
sauce sauce
okay good end opposite
just a little bit
[Music]
i
yeah
today
it's not
there yet but i learned a lot of stuff
about making this
yeah what do you think what how how good
did you do
68 yeah okay he agrees
he agrees i got a d plus
okay
[Music]
yes
okay
i made an omele rice food master eat a
d-plus
now i know how to go forward in practice
i don't have it yet but now i know what
i need to work on
yeah like no not many people can make it
like this short period of time so you
did great okay well
i'm gonna practice
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much this is so good
[Music]
thank you
okay i think we made a video
oh yes
[Music]
you